-Mon invité a la politique
dans le sang.
A 10 ans à peine,
il voulait devenir
maire de sa commune.
A 18 ans, il a pris
sa carte à l'UMP
pour finalement rejoindre
le Rassemblement National.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Kévin Mauvieux.
-Bonjour.
-La 1re prise de parole
d'un député
dans l'hémicycle,
c'est difficile,
il y a souvent
la voix qui tremble,
la bouche sèche,
la sueur au front,
et puis, quand on a des notes
à la main,
on voit la feuille qui tremble.
J'ai voulu voir
comment c'était pour vous.
J'ai les images,
c'était pendant
le projet de loi
sur le pouvoir d'achat
face à La France Insoumise.
*-Permettez-moi de vous renommer
le groupe "enfumage".
Vous prétendez défendre
le pouvoir d'achat des Français
et en réalité,
ça fait pas longtemps
qu'on a commencé à voter,
mais tout ce qui va
dans le sens du pouvoir d'achat,
vous votez contre.
Vous êtes encore là
pour faire le cirque,
faire un maximum d'amendements,
être visibles.
Mais les électeurs
ne s'y tromperont pas.
Ils vous voient, et ils voient
que vous êtes contre
tout ce qui peut augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat.
Que ce soit vos mesures ou pas,
vous votez contre.
-Vous parlez sans notes,
vous avez une voix
parfaitement posée.
Vous semblez très à l'aise,
comme si vous aviez fait ça
toute votre vie.
-Non, je n'ai pas fait ça
toute ma vie, mais...
-Vous avez des prédispositions
pour vous exprimer en public ?
-Peut-être que
dans la nature de chacun,
on a tous une prédisposition
pour quelque chose.
Certains sont plus artistiques
que d'autres.
Peut-être que j'ai
une prédisposition
pour prendre la parole
devant un public.
-Parce que vous n'aviez pas
de vraie carrière politique
avant ce jour-là,
avant votre élection à l'Assemblée.
Vous avez eu un engagement local
dont on va parler,
conseiller municipal
d'opposition.
-Ce qui a fait la réussite
de cette prise de parole,
c'est que j'ai juste parlé
avec mes tripes.
Quand on m'a proposé
d'être candidat
aux élections législatives,
je me suis posé la question,
et j'ai toujours été motivé
par mes convictions.
J'ai toujours défendu,
au sein de ma famille
et de mon entourage,
mes convictions.
Ce jour-là, j'étais dépassé
par le fait de pas pouvoir agir
pour les Français,
par une NUPES qui bloquait.
En fait, je me suis levé
et j'ai parlé
avec mes tripes.
-Alors, cette prise de parole
n'est pas passée inaperçue,
parce que dans les jours
qui ont suivi,
on a commencé à vous voir
dans les médias,
alors que la consigne
au sein du Rassemblement National,
c'était que les petits nouveaux
se fassent discrets
pour apprendre le métier
et laissent la parole à ceux
qui s'étaient déjà engagés
auprès de Marine Le Pen
dans son équipe de campagne
à la présidentielle.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
On vous a donné
un bon de sortie ?
-Je ne sais pas
si c'est un bon de sortie,
mais à la rentrée,
au mois de septembre,
on m'a dit : "Est-ce que
tu veux tenter les médias ?
"T'as une bonne
prise de parole
"dans l'hémicycle."
-Donc vous avez été repéré,
quand même, à ce moment-là ?
-Oui, certainement.
J'avais eu des compliments
après cette prise de parole
et celles que j'avais faites
pendant ce texte pouvoir d'achat
juste après l'élection,
Des compliments
m'avaient été remontés.
J'avais surpris par ma façon
ou mon aisance à parler
dans l'hémicycle.
Donc, on m'a proposé,
en septembre,
de tester les médias.
On a commencé
par une petite radio,
on a commencé avec LCP
et ça a fonctionné.
De fil en aiguille,
j'ai fait plus de médias.
Ca a abouti à ma nomination
de porte-parole
du groupe
Rassemblement National,
le vendredi du week-end
des Estivales à Beaucaire.
-En réalité, vous avez fait
des apparitions télé
avant d'être député,
dans un autre registre,
en tant que candidat
à des jeux télé.
Vous avez commencé
par "Le Juste Prix" avec Lagaf',
Il y a eu "Les 12 coups de midi",
"Que le meilleur gagne",
"Tout le monde
veut prendre sa place".
Vous n'aimez pas un peu
prendre la lumière ?
-Non.
Pour comprendre pourquoi
j'ai fait ces jeux,
pour être clair...
Effectivement j'ai commencé,
avec "Le Juste Prix"
parce que j'ai grandi
dans une famille populaire
et on se retrouvait
devant "Le Bigdil"
quand j'étais enfant,
on regardait "Le Bigdil" le soir.
J'ai toujours eu envie
de jouer avec Vincent Lagaf',
mais à mes 18 ans,
Vincent Lagaf ne faisait plus
"Le Bigdil"
mais "Le Juste Prix".
J'ai voulu participer
pour déconner,
et puis, pour une raison
que j'ignore,
j'ai été pris, j'ai participé,
j'ai perdu.
Ce qu'on ne sait pas avant,
c'est que quand vous faites
un jeu
et que vous êtes
plutôt apprécié,
on vous en propose d'autres.
Donc, j'en ai fait d'autres.
-D'autres députés
ont fait des jeux télé.
-C'est possible.
-Karl Olive en a fait
plus que vous.
Il est aussi passé
dans cette émission.
On a trouvé des images.
Son but, c'était de faire des jeux
pour remplacer l'animateur.
-Ah oui, d'accord !
J'en étais pas là.
-Mais vous avez un autre
point commun avec lui.
Vous avez tous les deux
un père ouvrier,
et grandi
dans un milieu populaire.
Vous l'avez déjà évoqué
et vous l'assumez,
vous le revendiquez.
-Je le revendique
car ce n'est pas le cas
de toute la classe politique,
mais après, on ne choisit pas
d'où on vient.
Et je le revendique
dans le sens où je trouve
que c'est une force.
Par exemple,
je vais présenter un texte
pour apporter
un complément de revenu
aux étudiants
qui travaillent.
Combien de députés pourraient
porter cette loi
en l'ayant vécue ?
Moi, j'ai travaillé
pour payer mes études.
-Vous avez exercé des métiers
très différents
avant d'arriver à l'Assemblée.
Vous avez été caissier
dans un supermarché
pour payer vos études,
vendeur de voitures,
animateur à Eurodisney,
conseiller bancaire,
assureur...
Il y a un point commun
à tous ces métiers ?
-Oui, c'est le lien
avec les gens.
C'est un lien différent
selon les métiers.
A la caisse,
vous n'êtes pas commercial
mais vous aidez les gens.
Vous êtes aussi
une oreille attentive
parce que vous avez plein de gens,
souvent âgés,
qui n'ont que vous
comme contact dans la journée.
Eurodisney,
c'est du spectacle,
mais c'est du contact
en permanence.
-Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas aussi
un côté vendeur, commercial...
Besoin de convaincre ?
-Oui, il y a un fil rouge
dans tout ça et qu'on retrouve
même dans le rôle de député.
C'est l'envie de convaincre.
Moi, je fais partie...
-Quand on vend des assurances,
quand on vend des voitures...
-Oui, je fais partie de...
Je sais que tout le monde
ne le pense pas.
Mais je fais partie de ceux
qui disaient toujours
que pour être un bon commercial,
il faut aimer le produit qu'on vend,
parce que le but,
c'est de convaincre.
La voiture, ça n'a pas duré,
parce que j'étais pas
fan de voitures.
L'assurance, ça allait.
Aujourd'hui,
je suis convaincu par les idées
que je défends, j'aime aller
au contact, convaincre.
Effectivement, c'est un fil rouge.
-La politique vous a intéressé
dès la primaire.
Vous vous étiez fixé
un objectif surprenant :
devenir maire de votre commune,
Pont-Audemer.
Qu'est-ce qui vous faisait rêver,
là-dedans ?
-C'était pas forcément du rêve,
parce que c'est un grand mot.
Je voulais pas être maire
pour être maire,
mais parce que j'avais,
dès l'école, cette appétence
pour être délégué, etc.
Je voulais défendre les gens,
améliorer le quotidien
et Pont-Audemer,
j'ai toujours vécu là-bas.
C'est une ville que j'aime
et que j'ai toujours voulu
améliorer.
Donc, dès mes 10 ans,
alors que j'étais dans un milieu
pas très politisé,
je me disais : "Je serai maire.
"J'ai de l'ambition pour ma ville."
-A 15 ans, vous êtes séduit
par Nicolas Sarkozy et son
"travailler plus pour gagner plus"
à la présidentielle 2007.
A 18 ans, vous prenez
votre carte à l'UMP.
Pourquoi l'UMP et pas le FN,
à l'époque ?
-Parce qu'à l'époque,
j'ai été séduit
par le discours de l'UMP
et le discours
de Nicolas Sarkozy,
qui était un vrai
discours de droite,
un discours de fermeté,
d'autorité,
qui mettait le travail en avant
avec le "travailler plus
pour gagner plus"
qui m'avait beaucoup séduit.
On le disait, j'ai grandi
dans un milieu modeste, ouvrier...
J'ai appris
qu'on avait rien sans rien
et qu'il fallait travailler
pour gagner de l'argent.
J'ai toujours voulu mettre
la valeur travail au centre.
Donc c'est cette campagne
de Nicolas Sarkozy
qui m'avait attiré.
-Vous avez milité
au sein des Républicains
jusqu'en 2022-2021.
Vous avez été élu
conseiller municipal
de Pont-Audemer.
Laurent Wauquiez
vous a même félicité
pour un de vos discours
lors d'un meeting.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a éloigné
de la droite ?
-Ce qui m'a éloigné
de la droite et de LR,
c'est leur rapprochement
avec la macronie.
Quand Emmanuel Macron
est arrivé au pouvoir,
dès le début,
j'ai dit que je m'opposais
à Emmanuel Macron,
le représentant indirect
de François Hollande.
Je sentais un petit peu
cette arrogance
qui naissait dans ce parti.
Mais les LR ont quand même
continué à entretenir
des relations.
Dans mon département, l'Eure,
on a Bruno Le Maire,
Sébastien Lecornu.
Dans la région, Edouard Philippe...
-Des ex-membres de la droite
ayant rejoint Emmanuel Macron.
-Oui, qui n'ont pas fait l'objet
d'attaques virulentes du parti
par rapport à leur départ.
Les LR sont devenus
si proches de la macronie,
et on le voit aujourd'hui,
que je ne pouvais pas rester.
-Donc, vous avez rejoint
le Rassemblement National
tardivement,
en février 2022,
quelques mois
avant les législatives.
Ca peut donner l'impression
d'une forme d'opportunisme.
Vous n'avez pas eu
ce que vous vouliez
du côté des Républicains,
vous êtes allé voir le RN,
qui cherchait des candidats
aux législatives.
-Non,
car si j'avais rejoint
le RN pour les élections,
déjà, j'y serais allé,
plus tôt,
parce qu'il y aller en février
4 mois avant l'élection,
c'est un peu fort de café,
et je les aurais rejoints
dès que j'ai quitté LR.
J'ai quitté LR pour les raisons
que j'ai citées.
J'ai attendu
avant de rejoindre le RN
parce que je voulais
m'imprégner du programme.
Je voulais m'assurer
que tout ce que les médias
vendent sur le RN
était faux.
Quand tout ça a été fait,
février 2022,
j'imaginais pas du tout
être candidat
aux élections législatives.
Je voulais juste participer
à la campagne
de Marine, qui me semblait
être la meilleure
pour incarner
la France d'aujourd'hui.
Mais il y avait absolument
aucune envie derrière,
en rejoignant le RN.
Il y a un an et demi,
qui pouvait dire
que des départements
comme l'Eure
basculeraient
au Rassemblement National ?
Pas grand monde,
donc ça aurait pas été
un très bon calcul.
-Vous êtes en politique
pour aider les gens,
sauf que vous siégez
dans l'opposition.
Vous vous sentez utile
en tant que député ?
-On se sent utile parce que
même si ce n'est pas
nos amendements
ou nos propositions
qui sont votés,
comme on est le 1er groupe
d'opposition,
on peut mettre une pression
sur le gouvernement.
La remise carburant est arrivée
parce qu'on a mis la pression.
Le gouvernement
n'en voulait pas.
Les chèques pour aider
les gens qui se chauffent
au bois ou au fioul,
c'est la même chose.
Plus récemment,
le harcèlement scolaire,
Gabriel Attal qui en fait sa cause,
qui a demandé
à ce que les harceleurs changent
d'école plutôt que la victime,
c'est ma proposition de loi
déposée au printemps.
Donc on ne vote pas nos textes
parce que ça fait pas bien,
mais ils s'en inspirent,
comme l'interdiction de l'abaya.
Tout ça, c'est des textes
et des idées qui viennent du RN,
qui sont de bon sens
et qui finissent par aboutir.
-On va passer à notre quiz.
Je vous explique.
Je commence une phrase
et c'est à vous de la compléter.
Etre le premier Kévin
élu à l'Assemblée,
c'est...
-Je suis le premier et demi
parce qu'on est rentrés
à deux en même temps, mais...
-Oui, c'est vrai.
-C'est gratifiant
et c'est valorisant.
Ca permet de montrer
qu'en France,
l'escalier social
fonctionne toujours.
L'escalier, pas l'ascenseur.
-C'est quand même
un symbole pour vous.
-C'est un symbole signifiant.
Kévin, Jordan,
c'était des prénoms associés
à des classes modestes,
populaires.
Je n'en suis pas convaincu,
mais ça y a toujours été associé.
Donc, je suis persuadé
que c'est le symbole
que quand on se donne les moyens
de monter sur l'escalier
de l'ascension sociale,
on peut le faire.
-Si j'étais gendarme...
Vous aviez passé le concours
de l'école de gendarmerie.
Vous l'aviez réussi,
mais vous y avez renoncé.
-Si j'étais gendarme,
je ne serais sûrement
pas là aujourd'hui,
puisqu'on ne peut pas faire
les deux en même temps.
-Il y a un devoir de réserve.
-Oui, mais il y a aussi
de grandes chances...
Vu le contexte actuel,
malheureusement,
j'aurais sûrement démissionné,
peut-être pour m'engager
en politique et pour défendre
les forces de l'ordre
et la gendarmerie
qui sont délaissées.
-L'Assemblée,
c'est comme un jeu télé...
-Oh là là... L'Assemblée,
c'est comme un jeu télé,
il y a des caméras
et des micros.
Mais alors, par contre,
à l'issue, ce qui est à gagner,
ce n'est pas une vitrine,
c'est l'avenir de la France.
-Ce sera
le mot de la fin.
Merci d'être venu dans l'émission.
-Merci à vous. Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA